actually by Design more emotional why  would that be an insult it's like saying  to somebody oh you're disabled [ __ ] your  legs like no you you're designed that  way why is that user as an insult to  women I I mean I think he's just talking  about like a lot of times women think  their feelings are reality so girls on  the girls on the show will come on the  show and say this is like this is how  the world is because of how I feel  basically but that is her reality  because that's how she's designed by  biology that's not what's true  so for so for example we could talk  about the pay Gap women could feel like  you make less than men but he would say  something like [ __ ] your feelings yeah  and so that that's the context that he's  using it